Troy's in New York City hey Troy how are
you good how are you Dave better than I
deserve what's up I have a question I am
tired of living paycheck to paycheck I
need your help on clearing this up okay
well there's really two things that
affect that the income and the outgo
right yeah so how much debt do you have
thirty thousand okay on what student
loans
car payment personal loan and through
credits what do you owe on your car I
owe 2,400 2,400 dollars
what are you all on your credit cards
that would be about six thousand okay
and so you've got a pretty substantial
student loan then around 20k or so yeah
23 gotcha okay cool and what's your
income last year 85 okay and I assume
you're renting yes how much is your rent
600 that's a deal
in New York City okay all right how old
are you 26 okay cool well you make good
money and you don't have a lot of
personal overhead what it takes you to
eat and get by and so it sounds like
more than anything you've got to get
just really intentional with these
dollars that's called a budget giving
every dollar an assignment before the
month begins because right now your
money is just going back out the door
like like like it's on fire or something
then you're spending money like you're
in Congress or something I don't know
where it's going but I mean you make
$85,000 of you have $600 rent in New
York City y'all be debt-free thirty
thousand bucks out of 85 what in under a
year and not have a payment in the world
but you're just gonna have to really
make that your focus rather than you
know partying or whatever it is you're
doing there's money I don't know where
it's going but you need to sit down and
do a written game
plan we're okay this is my check here
coming in at so many dollars I have
coming in this coming month and to start
with start at this coming month and say
alright that month here's what's going
to come in and here's what I'm going to
do with it you give each dollar a
mission each dollar an assignment and
the easiest way to do that is the every
dollar budget tool which is free to use
and just jump on inside it's our
budgeting tool that's absolutely
incredible takes you about 10 minutes to
put together your budget and you can put
do it on your iPhone or your Android or
on your desktop whatever you want to do
and just jump on every dollar comm and
download the apps for your phone or
whatever wherever you want to keep it
but I want you to make every dollar
behave I don't want you to wonder where
all this money went anymore and as soon
as you do that you're gonna have this
smack yourself in the forehead moment
where you go wow where's all this money
going you're gonna feel like you got a
raise those numbers will shame you and
you're going crap I gotta do better I
mean it's gonna give you that wake-up
call hold water and the face thing and
you know then you're gonna do better so
the good news is you've got a good
income you don't have a lot of overhead
and so you gotta be able to attack this
and make your money behave and really
get some sense attraction sense of power
about this this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]